Speaker 1: Let's get into the Friday mailbag,
the now world famous Friday mailbag. Technically,
we got one email from Zanzibar and now it's world
famous. Okay, let's get right into it. Remember,
you can email info at David Pakman dot com. You
can also contact us via a number of other means,
including Facebook, Twitter. Sometimes
YouTube comments will be featured. You
never know what you're going to have. But
today we start with a message from Facebook
and it is a very important message. And that
message is about President Joe Biden and the
things that I choose to report on. And this
individual says and I'm reading this as written,
I want to be clear. How much do you get from
Joe Biden to say that? Really? How much for
miss? That's misinformation, really? How much for
misinformation? Sir, please show me the respect
of addressing me as Mrs. Information.
Misinformation is extremely informal
for our relationship. Please. And of course,
this idea that we are funded by Joe Biden or
George Soros or the Trilateral Commission or the
Illuminati or the clause, Klaus Schwab. Gates So
who knows? Anyway, we're funded by people who
sign up on our website and by like YouTube ad
revenue and a few advertisers we have. There's no
secret that we're very, very clear about exactly
how we are funded. Next message is from Andrew.
Andrew wrote in with a suggestion saying, David,
try some honest journalism. I am pro vax, but no
longer pro COVID shot. I understand you have to
make this political or keep it political because
you have an audience to pander to. But please
don't mistake what you do for authentic
journalism. I see you, David. Remember,
I never claimed to do journalism. I claim to do
commentary, which is what I actually do. The very
disturbing lack of media literacy in this country
leads to messages like this, but more importantly,
pandering on the vaccine. I have to say the things
I'm saying because of my audience, I've been very,
very clear. The first vaccines seemed to prevent
infection and transmission. As the virus mutated,
the vaccines became less and less effective at
preventing infection and transmission, to the
point where my understanding of the latest data is
that the newest vaccines don't prevent infection
nor transmission. But they are still effective
at dramatically reducing the odds that you end
up in the hospital or dead. I've never hidden
that from the audience. I've been very clear,
so I don't know. Email someone who's actually
doing the things that you say I'm doing. I'm
getting quite bored with it. Here's someone who
writes in like 5 to 10 times a week. They go by
CAD. CAD wrote in and said, By the way,
by the way, right away, going into their
degrees reeks of either dishonesty or some some
kind of low self-esteem. OC cad writing. Yes,
I am highly educated with multiple degrees and
probably smarter than some of your audience
members. I love how you mock people and how
they talk because it's so hypocritical. You
were the one who made me do a deep dive and become
Republican. Thank you for that. I contribute to
society with my job helping others. I don't read
articles and then throw B.S. out for an hour and
a half with no pitch pushback. You're not as smart
as you think. Anyway. Do you ever watch yourself
on your show? You've got to be so smug because
your large teeth and mouse mouth movements are
so gross. Side profile, blah. That's the vomit
emoji. Why? Who the hell would ever go out with
someone so pompous as yourself? They'd have to
constantly stress from being corrected. You're
so feminine and your pronunciation is hysterical.
It's cringe. Many think you progressives are out
of your mind and ruining what was good about
this country. Go watch yourself. You are one
ugly dude. So before you get on a platform and
mock others, look in the mirror. What work of
yours should be valued besides mocking people?
I guess that's a statement, not a question.
You know, I used to get upset about messages like
this because someone is there criticizing so many
things about me. And then one of the kind
of awakenings I had was I thought to myself,
you know, I watched. Lots of different things.
I've never written to anyone that is the host
of any show I watch ever. And if I did, I would
be embarrassed to send messages like this because
they're so bizarre and out there. And so then I
imagined what kind of person would even send a
message like this. What must their life be like
where they have either the time or the idea or
the interest of saying, I'm going to go over to my
computer or pull out my phone and write something
like this to someone I don't even know. And then I
realized how sad the lives of the trolls must be.
And then I stopped worrying about them. I actually
kind of just feel bad now. And I've spoken to some
other people about it, and they do what I do,
and they sort of come to a similar position.
And it really is sad. It really is sad. What
must be going on in someone's life to think, to
write something like that to someone else. Anyway,
let's get into some of the more substantive stuff.
Andrew from Oregon wrote in with an interesting
message. He said, One effective question to ask
anti-vaxxers. Hey David, long time watcher, love
your work. As COVID has seen a recent uptick and
it doesn't seem like it's going away anytime soon.
The debate over preventative measures continues to
rage. I've found a really effective way to stump
anti-vaxxers is to ask them what group of experts
informs your COVID views. They may point to
cherry pick data devoid of context or individuals
who share their view, but never a collection of
experts. There isn't a university, a hospital or
scientific body of any sort they rely on every
time it seems to promote, promote, provoke a
moment of self-reflection on the veracity of the
source of their information. And I find it's a
great foundation to build from. Yeah, this is
an interesting idea because often the science
deniers will say, ignore everything all doctors
say, except this one radiologist who's commenting
about vaccines despite it being completely
outside his or her area of expertise. And the
question is an interesting one, because when you
say what group of experts, they often will say,
well, you really can't trust immunologists. Now
you have to trust this one person. All the other
immunologists are wrong, or you can't really trust
pulmonologists because they mostly are lying about
COVID. But this one pulmonologist has has gotten
outside of the bubble. It is a good question,
and I think only with some people, only with
people who are most open to having their views
examined, would it would it have an impact.
But it is an interesting idea because it's
not about expertise. It's about finding people
that already agree with them and then saying,
here's who I'm going to listen to. And I've
met people personally during the pandemic who
early in the pandemic said, these are the these
are the three people that you can really trust
during the pandemic. Those three people's views
have changed as informed by data and science. And
then the people who used to go to them say they
they are no longer trustworthy. Here's the other
people I now trust. Well, it's not that the
people are less trustworthy. It's that you no
longer agree with the things that they're saying.
And it is it is something I see quite often. P.K.
wrote in sort of a tongue in cheek response to
that guy who called in recently and attacked me
for being not that tall. And P.K. wrote in about
David's height and weight, says, Dear David, I am
five eight and weigh 165. That obviously gives me
a £15 intellectual advantage over you. I'm sorry,
sir, but that's just the science. Thank you for
your time. Yes. And obviously, this individual
outweighs me by £15, but it's £15 of brain matter.
Certainly, I have to make a correction. And I'm
glad Katherine from the U.K. is helping
me do that. I wrongly stated the other day
in passing and as a complete joke
that the coleslaw at KFC is vegan.
Katherine wrote in and said, Hey, David, watching
the video about Bolsonaro in Florida and was keen
when you mentioned the coleslaw from KFC being
vegan. I'm in the UK where the slaw is not vegan,
so I had a look. It's not vegan in the US either.
Unfortunately, it's vegan in Canada. I understand
though perhaps there is hope for the rest
of the world. Okay. Yeah. I don't know. I
don't really know anything about KFC coleslaw.
I remembered that producer Pat once told me the
KFC coleslaw was vegan. Pat has no recollection
of that, so I don't really know where I got it,
but I don't go to KFC, and I'm also not vegan. So
it ended up being sort of sort of a moot point,
I guess we would say. Oliver wrote in about the
phenomenon of the day. Oliver says, Hey, David,
have you noticed that many, especially on the
right, are increasingly used? Using the term.
They too define political opposition, for example.
They want to silence us. They want to sexualize
children. They are the elite. Is this just a
symptom of seemingly populist rhetoric with those
on the other side thrown into the one basket, i.e.
the elite with no room for substance? Or does it
boil down to something else entirely? That's all
from Scotland. I don't think they know what they
mean. I've had conversations where they'll say
I'm doing it too. It is an interesting shorthand.
Right wingers who call me let me be precise.
Sometimes some right wingers who call me will say
they are not allowing us to investigate the
origins of COVID. And I'll say, Who is they?
Is it Democrats? And they'll go, Well, no, it's
not really Democrats. No. Is it the media? Is the
media preventing anybody from. No, it's not
really the media, is it? I don't know. Like,
is it Marxists? Because that's an off and often
used trope. No, it's not. And then you see,
they don't even know who they is. So as a
rhetorical technique, I do think it can sometimes
be useful to say to those with whom you are
speaking. Who is they, exactly? It's not Biden.
It's not Hunter. It's not Fauci. It's not, you
know, Anderson Cooper Who is it exactly? And
some of them are slicker and they will be more
prepared and they'll say something like I say,
they because it's the establishment, it's no one
person, but it's the total atmosphere created by
the. Oh, okay. RSA. But it's a good question. Who.
What do you mean by that? I think it is a it's a
useful technique. Email in info at David Pakman
dot com and please come on over to the bonus show
you can sign up at join packman dot com. You can
get instant access and it's an extra show every
single day for our website members you can use
the coupon code 24 starts now at Join patricof.